thank you first of all for the
opportunity to be here it is an honor
and it's really fun to see these forty
year celebrations happening in
individual programs looking back on
their successes and how they sort of
grew where they were planted so it was
great to be here I also brought I bring
you greetings from the NCC PA wearing
that hat and like most program directors
I wear more than one hat and so I also
bring you greetings from the University
of Washington for medics northwestern
from Dick Smith our founder who said
especially wanting to thank all of you
and recalling some good memories so
while you've heard a quantitative
presentation a qualitative presentation
this is going to be served like an
editorial preservation presentation sort
of ruse observations on what's going on
I can't possibly include everybody or
every name of what's happening but I
sort of wanted to talk about the trends
I don't think I can duplicate the pig
story but i'll try to have a few stories
mixed in here so why are we worried
about this well i think everybody's more
and more aware and even a more aware as
time going on goes on that health
workforce is the global solution and i
guess it really should say and that pas
are part of the answer part of the part
of the part of the solution so whether
we're thinking about the brain drain in
Africa or whether we're thinking about
shortages here or the change in
distribution different countries are of
their own choice beginning to look at
pas and as as American p organizations
each of our each of our organizations
has tried to figure out whether that's
our problem whether we should address it
there's a lot of contrary controversy
about this as justine said though the
conversation really increases the
vitality in our own profession because
it causes us to look back at some of the
things we've done and it's also
fascinating that if as you talk to
people around the world one of the
things they they say just in quick
summary before I begin is as we move
ahead is taken you 40 years to get to
where you are and it's fun to talk about
that but in and you had a lot
experiences some work and some didn't if
we learn from you could we just kind of
collapse the 40 years into 10 years and
get through some of this con
licked and so I think that's sort of a
good goal because there are things that
have worked in there things that happen
and there are also some sort of sort of
trends that are fascinating so when we
think about here are just some examples
of PAS internationally and of course you
know that we weren't the first that the
filters that Peter Peter the Great had
with his army were really some of the
first people that had this role none of
these were exactly the same role as we
had here you can read through them a lot
of people are not aware that in the 70s
when many of the African countries went
through civil war all of the European
doctors left and returned to Europe
leaving vacuums in healthcare and so
there were PA like programs that were
started they're not really pas but
they're very similar and they're
fascinating to learn about and same with
South America so if you look at Guyana
for example you'll see us actually they
happen to be called medics is there
because they came out of work that dick
smith did but there are around the world
Fitz Mullen wrote an article about
non-physician providers and mid-level
providers in sub-saharan Africa a couple
of years ago and so there's some
fascinating examples to think where did
this come from and where is it all going
so what's in a name a favorite topic for
a place like Yale
and a favorite topic actually for a
place like the medics program and I
regret Patrick that I forgot to put
child health associates on here so but I
think one of the things we've sort of
all learned is that we probably can't
control this in different countries in
the world are going to come to their own
conclusions in fact if you're in the UK
and you read the advertising for one
edge you'll see that there's a lot of
jobs for pas but what those are our
personal assistants actually that are
served like secretaries that work for
you so pas are probably not necessarily
the right word there either so we can
get hung up on that so the founder of
the medics program dick smith who was
one of the first medical directors for
the Peace Corps went on to do a lot of
work in creating health professions
around the world that were mid-level
like and he created sort of a list of
how you might actually do that so I've
sort of changed that taking this list I
want to share it with you because it's
interesting to see apply this list and
see as we look at some of the models
around the world's what worked and what
hasn't and that's even true here so
sometimes we've seen countries for
example or a particular Hospital in a
country a particular state in the
country that decided based on maybe one
person's point of view that it would be
good to create the PA profession but
they didn't do the needs assessment they
didn't check with anybody else they just
thought about what was their their own
little need they had and that didn't
work it also hasn't worked when there
hasn't been community collaboration so
we've heard some examples here today of
some of the history and really involving
the community and also the the
practitioners of physicians the nurses
whatever so it's about stakeholders a
lot of times most programs that if if
you look at that have been successful
have oh I guess we could call
competency-based training but basically
we heard a number of great stories
whether it was talking about pas being
the data collectors that did something
and that person who does that in just a
short period of time compared to
somebody who isn't thinking in an
organized way but thinking about what do
you really want people to do and how do
you train them for that and not waste
time on other things especially when
we've got limited resources and how do
you deal with that another feature is
the idea of thinking what are you going
to do with these people
do you need them for and in some places
it turns out that it's not primary care
which is what we thought and primary
care might be a political hot potato
some places it's surgery I'm going to
have a list of other things other
examples here but to me the one I've
highlighted most is the idea of the
receptive framework and you heard Blair
talked about this this morning which is
really the idea that it isn't just in
his case he was talking about the legal
piece of it but if you really are going
to create a safety net for a new
profession as it as it evolves you have
to think not just the easiest thing as a
training program in the curriculum and
you can sort of make it up as you go
along as we all know but you have to
think how does this fit into the
political system how's it fit into the
legal system how does it fit into the
reimbursement system and you have to
start those from the very beginning you
don't just start the program and then
later on say oh by the way we should
have thought whatever and so you see the
pas for example in the UK right now
they're sort of stalled out we have
American pas over there there are three
PA programs the one has just been shot
down another a couple of new ones are
starting but the problem is they can't
figure out where they fit in the
regulatory structure do they fit under
allied health do they fit under the
physicians which would take longer right
now they're functioning under the
delegate Ori model but nobody can figure
it out because that's not what they did
to start with was thinking about that so
think of this receptive framework as you
think about starting any sort of new
ideas this happens to be the medics
series that dick use to Train health
workers how many countries Justin many
20 or 30 around the world so how did we
get into this how did people around the
world start looking at pas well you
wouldn't be surprised to know it's
probably because of individual pas so
you had examples of military deployment
so in many countries in the world as
part of our military actions there were
pas who were in the military who were
deployed not just take care of our own
soldiers but they had community service
of obligations they of their own choice
waded out into the community and because
we can't stop from doing that they did
health promotion activities people began
to be aware of them they were very
visible the military at various times
has really promoted pas
as a way of talking about the good
health care within their own system
there have been pas in the Peace Corps
there are many places in the world where
the PAS have been the medical officers
for a region pas went overseas as part
of religious missions and all this is in
countries were there there's no law that
allows us to do this but informally be
particularly because the regulatory
framework is not well established
everywhere in the world necessarily or
because pas were employed by
corporations or other entities they
could go overseas and technically
practice because they had this this
relationship that allowed them to do
that educational programs and projects
many people especially people that are
PA faculty people have been overseas
working on training other kinds of
health providers whether it's teaching
pelvic exams to medical students in
Saudi Arabia because it's not okay to
teach it there by Saudi Arabian medical
educators there's an interesting one so
we've been out there we've been visible
in epidemics we've been visible in
global emergencies and the other thing
that's happened is a lot of physicians
from around the world have trained here
in the US and when they've trained here
they've gone back and said where is my
PA I can't function without this PA
really made things work better and
that's actually a real mobilizing force
in many countries around the world and
I'm constantly meeting people who say
that why can't you help us get this here
faster than it's coming so again all
about the individual pas and they will
tell me the stories of who it was ill
know where they went to school they'll
know all about their training and they
want to know why is this not happening
fast enough so we had some issues
ourselves here to begin with is this
like this was sort of taking on and I
think pas ourselves had some trouble
coming to terms with this so on the one
hand of course we believe that PA zar a
model that could work anywhere in the
world but there were some of us who also
said but you know we've got enough
problems at home to deal with there's
only so much we can take on so if PA
programs were sending students for
example overseas to international
tations then did that mean they weren't
willing to go to a community health
center and they're in their neighboring
state because they'd spent all their
money traveling to wherever it was so
there was a lot of debate among
ourselves about what our priorities were
and could we do everything there also
was some all love youth my words
carefully jealousy hostility anxiety
whatever about their end sumith some
sort of urban myths about the
individuals that were doing some of this
work Americans that were going over
faculty members PA program leaders and
somehow there became this this thinking
that these people were making huge
amount of money as consultants I've
never met anybody that that was the case
and in fact most people that were doing
this either paid their own way or paid
their expenses to do it but they were
doing it for the same reason that we all
are promoting pas generally because it
was the right thing to do and it took a
while for that to sort of shake out we
we still are not big enough in our
profession yet that we can't get past
some of the personality issues and I
know Patrick would cheer me on and
saying that so so we just sort of come
to terms with this ourselves and then
there was the issue of can we control
this and meaning can we control the name
can we control the curriculum can we
control what these people do well they
want to come back here do they see this
away is a backdoor into medical practice
in the US and were they really going to
be looking for reciprocity well it turns
out our regulatory structure in the
United States is so difficult that even
if there were everything a centralized
curriculum sent international exam which
would be impossible to make each state
has its own regulatory requirements and
so that's probably not worth spending a
lot of time on but we had to we had to
get there and I think some of the
conversation was very good different
organizations got involved in this and
essentially I think both AAPA and Paea
kind of said there's only so much we can
do we're happy to host people were happy
to visit them have them visit but we
can't make it a big right Patrick of
this can't be our big agenda item and
Justin having been president of the paea
what I'm sure agree with me so figuring
out what the right thing to do what
in the meantime the NCC PA felt like it
had a little different issue here which
was we were being asked questions about
certification by the way not should we
take in it should we have an
international certifying exam but how
could we help these countries that are
wanting to create some sort of
certifying exam process and teach them
about how to do test item banks teach
them what we did right what we did wrong
and really help them with the regulatory
the receptor framework part of this so
as a result we've hosted a number of
meetings and I've traveled around a lot
to talk about promoting the PA
profession broadly so that's that sort
of the background on this so if we were
to ask Dick Smith back in his days of
thinking about how do you do something
internationally he would have said this
which is kind of where we think have
gotten to which is that it's okay for
countries to adapt this idea to what
makes sense for them and not to adopt
our model with the stencil essentially
spray-painted on the wall but that you
have to let countries make it be their
own choice and then that's when it gets
interesting so how did PA programs and
how did people get involved in this well
first of all there were a lot of initial
contacts people met people and they went
overseas to talk now Elaine is a good
example I know of this because she at
one point spent time in the UK talking
about pas and surgery early on so that's
an example that they have that there
were people from ministries of health
and large hospitals that came to the
u.s. to visit and they typically went to
sort of the obvious PA programs I know
they came here they came to GW they came
to juke that came to medics and they
wanted to hear about tell us what you're
doing and then they invited us over and
so a number of us went hundreds of
people of various times representing
different organizations all pretty much
I think with the same with the same
message in doing a great job and then
the other thing that sort of happened
all along the line was that a number of
institutions there were global health
things that were going on anyway and so
because we are now more broadly viewed
within our own medical schools or
institutions we were invited along for
the conversation now sometimes we like
that and some
times we didn't and so so I know you've
had some opportunities to be in Africa
and anyway we had a number of things
that we had to sort of work with was
that good or bad so here are just some
examples of those so this is actually
some a lot of these pictures are just of
myself not because this is about me but
because i have this slide set about
where I've been so this happens to be in
China but and I picked it because of how
bright color it is but it could be
anywhere in the world and it could have
been in lane talking in the UK about
surgeons that could have been Justine
talking and Mozambique it could have
been rod hooker anyway we started doing
these talks and then we had people come
to the u.s. to visit and then we went to
visit places this happens to be at a
rural health center remote rural health
center in Australia and here we are this
is Justine actually in Seattle speaking
Portuguese with a number of people
working on a clinic on a project to
redefine the entire curriculum for the
PA like people in Mozambique who by the
way have the coolest name it's much
cooler than any our names and their name
is tecnicos so think about that it
doesn't serve a way of the future anyway
and then then there became a chance for
us to participate in international
meeting so this is a so CA shin of
medical educators that in Europe ants
myself and Janet Lathrop talking about
physician PA teams this is a meeting
with the in South Africa with two Dean's
at the University of Cape Town this is a
meeting that a number of us participated
in international workforce collaborative
there a number of meetings that are
going on internationally they're talking
about who are the people that should
provide medical care and they're quite
broad minded conversations this is a
meeting in South Africa and here you see
David feringer from Kentucky and the
person in the orange tie is Phil bag
from the University of Wolverhampton the
UK first PA program in the UK and the
person to the left is a person with the
Department of Health and in South Africa
and what it all came down to I'm
reminded of Mary Ann and all the
conversation she's had with people a lot
of it was about meeting with people on
policymakers will
one this happens to be a Warren Snowdon
who is the Minister of Health Affairs
for rural Australia Health Affairs for
rural and remote Australia and
Aboriginal health and you can imagine
what the conversation was so he wanted
to know how could this happen can you
prove to me that if we train pas they'll
actually end up where you want them to
be not working in the cities and so
working on that was coming along so here
were some early projects the Netherlands
had the first PA programs overseas and
in Europe and they were there for there
and they really are designed to train
people for their large hospitals
training employees that already work
there taiwan trained a number of nurses
who actually very few of whom practice
in pas s pas and then PA programs began
having these international student
rotations which was also a subject of
conversation about whether that was an
appropriate use of PA student time but
this is happening over the last 10 or 15
years so then there were a series of
pilot projects and it's quite fun if you
ever want to read about these there are
written reports of all these so you only
have to go to the country and google p a
pilot project evaluation the United
Kingdom anybody in this group was has
participated a pilot yeah so so they
they are fascinating that you should
were conducted by the Ministry of Health
right and they paid the salaries of the
PAS and the fascinating thing first of
all you'll notice they're all
Commonwealth countries are formal and
Commonwealth countries so they're all
english-speaking countries so that is
the limitation but they actually learn
from each other so they actually talk to
each other so the people as they were
doing one project in the UK it was
ambulatory an emergency medicine
Scotland continued from that Ontario in
Canada had an interesting pilot which
was really about imgs it turned out not
really to be about pas it had over 65
people and about 45 of a more
international medical graduates and
that's really what they were testing but
it was emergency medicine queensland
australia ruolin
moat health but also cardiology in an
urban setting South Australia surgery
role and New Zealand is just has an
inpatient surgical experience really
more of a hospice program and each of
those funded by the Ministry of Health
very well funded for evaluation and so
suddenly some literature and some
evidence beginning to come out about pas
it actually reflects quite interestingly
on ourselves what a lot of these pilots
say is that the PAS aren't the full
substitute for a physician what we
probably mostly would agree with that
because of the roles they put them in
but really what they brought to the mix
was they made it more efficient and they
were the brokers of communication among
the people that worked in him now that's
not too surprising for us and those of
us who educators love to hear that but
it really was about the role they played
in the relationships that they had is
really what made this work and the other
thing that made at work was a
relationship between the physician and
the PA if that worked it worked well and
if it didn't work so well it didn't work
so well now we all know that but it's
fun to see it in the literature and it's
fun to see it from people who aren't us
looking at it but from international
evaluate errs so this these happen to be
the pilot the people that were in the
pilot in Australia as well as the people
that are in the tube in the PA programs
in Australia so the gentleman in the in
the front here on the left he looks a
little bit like Richard Gere is actually
Richard Murray who's the Dean of James
Cook University next to him is Alfred
who is a was the former clinical
coordinator at Utah and then there's a
the first pas that were there and then
the person here on the far the far left
who you can see best is Alex Clare font
who is now you see gone back to UC Davis
so this was this was a land all the
women in that pilot all the people in
that pilot actually turned out to be
women which was interesting so then I
wanted to show you quickly through some
of these new programs this was this
isn't Birmingham University of
Birmingham and the person at the far end
is Jim parl who's the doc who was the
physician champion for that and sort of
next to him you can barely see Miss Dave
kunz whose many of you now who's done
international stuff so Birmingham and
Wolverhampton started about the same
time and one of the American faculty
that was there as a woman in the blue
sweater who's Theresa Johnson who has
worked at a couple of programs 11 in
Florida and one in North Carolina this
is Joel Grey who is not the short Joel
Grey the dancer but at all Joel Grey an
American PA who's the head of the PA
program at st. George's University in
London and interestingly enough he got
hired for this job and never been a
faculty member before in his life and in
some ways has done some one of the best
jobs really great guy and this is in
Australia this is the University of
Queensland in Brisbane and then these
are the two guys sitting in the front
are in the very first class at the
University of Queensland in Brisbane
don't graduate on jun 17 so that's
pretty exciting and you see Alfred there
so so why did why did some institutions
or why did some states want to do this
and what I'm hope you mostly get are
sort of the range of things so we talked
about the Netherlands Queensland South
Australia New Zealand is interesting
because it's a small country and it's a
little bit like Connecticut you could
sort of do all the things that
self-contained and you could actually
make some change and they're really
looking at a trolls of a mixed kind of
roles that turns out that of the
physicians they trained in in New
Zealand sixty percent of them take jobs
in Australia so you think they could do
something about that but anyway and then
here are some things that weren't pilots
so you in South Africa is clearly for
rural regional hospitals and by the way
when I saw this I thought rural regional
hospitals I'm thinking Washington State
you know 20 beds you know whatever no
we're talking 300 beds but still rural
and remote without any physicians there
Ghana has two models well we know that
it's good to have more than one model
was to upgrade health workers and one
was a generic program related to a
four-year college George Washington
University not the PA program but the
department of emergency medicine is
working with Saudi Arabia British
Columbia which still can't decide
whether it wants pas or not does know
why they would want them interesting
thing about Canada is that of several of
Canadian provinces you would think they
would all agree the Canadian provinces
no no no no no they all have to have
their own world and their own identity
and their regulation of physicians is
accomplished through a College of
Physicians and Surgeons and it turns out
you have to have a license if you're a
medical student your license starts the
moment you enter Medical School so to
send PA students there even for
rotations they would have to be licensed
and that licensure doesn't exist so
extra bumps in the road you wouldn't
think and it's interesting that China
has lots of doctors of various types but
the one unmet need they have is dealing
with the health care problems of migrant
workers who are not the usual migrant
workers that we think here but people
migrating from small rural communities
and to serve the huge Nike tennis shoe
factories and the problems that they're
having lived in very concentrated areas
and nobody's caring about their health
and think about the health care problems
that we go with that so here are some
more reasons Ireland is thinking about
surgery roles so what makes what makes
the difference so it's really fun to me
to hear this morning as we sort of
relive the start of this program to see
that the story is very similar
everywhere you go in the world and one
of the reasons it's similar well first
of all there's a need but they start
with some sort of physician champion or
champions and the thing that these
individuals have in common is
I say this affectionately they are all
characters I mean they are fascinating
people to talk to their innovators they
have they can always think of a new way
to do things that's fascinating to talk
to them because they'll say well we
could do this or we could do that we
could do that they are risk takers they
don't get dragged down by personalities
and so it's fascinating to meet them and
you feel like I've known these people
for other whatever whether it's jeans
dead or dick smith or these people in
this room today they're all part of the
same family I don't know if they have
the same personality type or something
but there's certainly optimists they
don't take no for an answer they don't
they question authority is that right
and they're innovative and but they know
how to work the system so I'll let you
make up the rest of the story but it's
fascinating to see who they are
everybody has benefited from the US
experience in that they know about it
they might not want to do it the same
way we do it but they still have
benefited from that experience almost
every time there's a specific problem
they're solving and I've sort of spelled
out what some of those problems are and
I think everybody's very interested in
globalization so we're aware that what's
happening in one place we probably ought
to know about and that there must be
something to learn from that so for
example in I was fascinated to find out
that in Europe they don't have board
exams for physicians you don't take them
afterwards after you graduate instead
and there's a reason for this instead
you take an exam before you graduate
from your medical school and that makes
you a physician or a doctor whatever
they're calling you in that particular
place and that's it your certificate of
your graduation certificate allows you
to practice so when you talk about
creating some sort of board exam for pas
it pretty much has to be something they
would do before they graduate and and
then to try to standardize it in some
way within the country so it's not just
coming from one program so the reason
that they don't want to have national
board exams for physicians is because of
the European community any student
anywhere in any kind
we can apply to medical school anywhere
and so they don't want the medical
schools to be ranked because everybody
would then glom on to that particular
one and there would be poor distribution
across medical school so that's I would
have never guessed that so what are the
barriers we've talked a lot about the
physician culture and I do think it's
often the physician culture on the
ground level and you just seen was just
talking about the less sort of authority
people have the more threatened they are
by this nursing what can you say and it
and this is not necessarily saying
anything bad about nursing actually it's
just that nursing particularly is often
opposed to nurse practitioners as much
as they are two nurses and that was
originally are two pas and that was part
of the original history i graduated in
seventy six or seven or something like
that and i was shocked when i went out
to find and went back to my small town
hospital that they were harder on my
colleague who had gone to nurse
practitioner school than they were on me
because they had more of a checklist for
her and she was also sort of crossing
over from she crossed over to the dark
side from their point of view and and
that was really bad they knew I was a
troublemaker so that they could kind of
live with that so so in many countries
where nurses have had expanded roles and
this is particularly true in
Commonwealth countries where we don't
have there isn't the same culture of BSN
nurses and msn nurses there still are
wonderful three year nurses who are very
well trained and who feel like the fact
that there are new roles whether their
pas or NPS demeans what they're doing is
kind of like what am I chopped liver
sort of argument you know don't you care
about all the things I've done so it's a
very different kind of view than we get
from nurses now and I think it actually
makes sense the nurse practitioner issue
is also interesting because nurse
practitioners in most countries as they
did here in the US and maybe they still
do feel unsupported in general so we
have the benefit of our relationships
with physicians but nurse practitioners
often feel disenfranchised around the
world
and as well there may have been nurse
practitioner programs that started in
some places they they have not always
been successful and one of the reasons
is that it seems as though the culture
ization of some nurse practitioner
programs has been to to demean
physicians so in British Columbia for
example they have trained I think about
four cohorts of nurse practitioners and
none of are employed and the reason even
though they've been paid for by the
government and the reason is that they
go out and they put them in a clinic the
government's paying for them but the
first thing they say is to the doctor I
don't need you well that's not very
helpful way to approach anything if you
think about it so sometimes in some
countries the view is what we've already
invested in these NPS it isn't working
so therefore we don't need pas so
reframing the argument to say maybe if
you have both and move them along
together sometimes works in some
countries rather than just one or the
other junior doctors we don't have
junior doctors in our country but but
most of most of Commonwealth countries
do and junior doctors are two kinds of
people their residents so some of the
concern was in Australia that if we have
pas will take away all their good
teaching patients we've heard that here
early on doesn't happen but that was
their concern but it turns out there's
actually sort of a status of person that
you can actually stay sort of a resident
or a junior doctor forever you never
have to leave home if you choose to
never leave home and so that allows you
to keep a hospital is kind of role
that's sort of a little lower level it
kind of looks like a PA actually and
particularly in Australia and some other
countries is unionized so those unions
have really been opposing the creation
of PAS that took us a while to figure
out what they were talking about because
we said why are those residents so
worried about it but it sees junior
doctors that feel disenfranchised and
similarly that's also the case of some
international medical graduates
Australia has huge numbers of imgs that
that actually take care of people in
their remote communities is not so much
a problem that
imgs would be offended to have someone
else there the issue is if you create
training programs the sort of training
program so we would have usually used in
PA programs to train pas and rural areas
you couldn't do that because the IMG SRC
a students that you're trying to
familiarize with the u.s. system and
then there's the languages issue that
there are still countries doing this in
other languages and our materials are
not translatable our situations don't
move over as easily so those are some of
the barriers so here are some things
just quickly that plus and minus that
you see as you work through this so one
is that that it's a big delay when
there's a turnover in government so this
has been the issue in British Columbian
in Queensland just when you've got it
all straightened out and you think
you've talked to everybody in the
Ministry of Health and the Minister of
Health and you've got them all convinced
then suddenly someone calls an election
and that person's gone in another
person's in and sometimes that sometimes
you're happy to have the person gone and
another person in but also their entire
cabinet so you have to start all over
and rebuild the relationship with the
new minister of rural and Aboriginal
health new technology the University of
Queensland is sort of experimenting with
some online coursework for much of their
didactic courses there are however some
people there saying well it can't
possibly as good be as good a program as
USPA programs because it's not all
face-to-face I don't know hard to figure
it out in general expanded roles for
health professionals in general so in
the UK for example there was a law
passed that said that regulated Health
Professions could have prescriptive
privileges sounds good turns out pas
fall under the delegate Ori model they
haven't decided yet where they want to
follow under the regulatory model so
pharmacists certain kinds of nurses and
so forth can prescribe but pas can't
because they're not regulated so
epidemics we're having issues of pas
going overseas sometimes they're allowed
to practice and sometimes they're not
and sometimes that's broken down the
door in a good way we're all concerned
about health profession shortages
Australia again is a good example they
were so worried about this because they
well they have a huge growth of people
coming into Australia so about eight
years ago they decided in one swoop to
double the number of medical students in
the entire country double it all at once
well that sounds like a good idea but
think of the hell that that cause just
many of your educators think of the hell
that caused with clinical sites and so
it began to be viewed as the medical
student tsunami and everybody in
Australia knows what that's about so
first we had not enough now we have too
many and they're clogging up the system
and and they've it's ridiculously
expensive to train that many people and
so how do you superimpose pas on that
what you probably still need to for some
things but it's a little harder to make
the argument and then there's the growth
and expansion of medical schools and one
thing I would challenge you that are
interested in research to do is that
there is no research written research or
evidence about the roles that PA is
playing medical education so we all know
that in our medical schools are the PAS
that work there teach medical students
to do all kinds of things and so
actually in the tsunami of medical
students in Australia the reality is
there are some American pays that are
going there to teach and our teaching
clinical skills and so forth but there's
no evidence in our literature so there's
an assignment for somebody to work on so
these are some of the things that we
still need to think about the whole
issue of regulation or delegation which
we talked about who is going to license
or regulate these people we still
haven't solved the problem of
international accreditation the wh 0
does have an accreditation process for
medical schools and again not for
reciprocity but sort of some sort of a
framework and the big question that's
everybody's asking is what is the
economic practice model so here in the
US we know that you can bill insurance
companies you get paid or you don't get
paid medicare medicaid pays as we can
argue about the percentages but what
happens in British Columbia or Australia
where everybody is paid by their
salaries paid by the by the government
what is the incentive for a doc to have
a PA that here
you should supervise unless they get
paid a super visual supervisory rate for
example so a lot of things to think
through and understand and the other
thing that people are asking overseas is
should we market people they're sort of
shocked to know that we marketed
ourselves that's a big big change i bet
patrick has had some experiences some of
the rest of you that have been
presidents that I say well what are you
doing to market yourself in the UK or
whatever and it's a foreign idea
professionals don't health professionals
don't really write on market themselves
i'm talking about the profession not
individual people so now we're getting
some more evidence about all of this and
that's going to be one of the benefits
of this whole things we have proceedings
of policy meetings to talk about pas
that weren't available before we have
there's been lots of opportunities for
talking posters whatever that have
entered the literature the evaluation
reports are especially rich fun to read
either that or is something wrong with
me if I think those are fun to read but
they're fun to read about ourselves
first person articles the first PA here
is writing about whatever the Ministry
of Health proposals and implementation
documents and the governance and
regulatory documents so we're getting a
rich amount of information to help us
work through these things and again I
think our role is to provide technical
assistance but to assume that everyone
will make their own choices so just
quickly to end three stages of a new
idea and I and by visiting different
countries I get to experience all of
these so and we experience this to begin
with that at first this seems like the
most ridiculous thing I've ever heard of
and why would you think that people that
weren't doctors should do doctor like
things well it turns out the next stage
is its controversy and we still have
some places we heard some examples where
things are still a little bit
controversial is true for pas and nurse
practitioners sort of parallel buts
controversial and some of us would think
if we asked Burdine and if we ask
Marianne and if we asked Bruce and some
people we'd hear that you know actually
this controversial parts some of the
most fun part I think I still think that
because there's room for some
interesting solutions and very lastly we
get to say where we mostly are but
there's still more work to do and that
is where it's obvious so thank you for
your time